PEGI 18
today I have a surprise for you as we
said and this surprise is a new IP in a
new genre and this game couldn't wait
till the end of the show
you
this game is about the the sort of love
of combat and the love of martial combat
a particular I have always believed I
have this deep belief actually the
combat is an art form it's brand new
experience where you will finally live
the true motion of being behind a
weapons in a close quarter combat
are you a knight are you a Viking are
you a samurai let you discover what your
inner warrior is like because that's the
whole purpose when I when a person picks
up a weapon right they become a warrior
right so we want to create that
experience in a videogame context when I
say night biking or samurai I'm not
asking you what your favorite is I'm
asking you what you value people who
answer samurai tend to value skill
mastery honor right people who value
Viking tend to value freedom and
expression and enthusiasm and
celebration right and people who choose
Knights tend to value culture and
defense and sort of nobility and like
the sort of codes that sort of stuff
right so it really is this statement
about what do you believe in right which
is just incredibly powerful so that's
the basis of the whole thing
first we had a team we had a very strong
team on the Fox team who had been
building some you know experience on on
fighting systems and fighting game and
and then and then we got Jason
Vandenberg Jason had this this game
within himself everything started three
years ago now it's going fast when I met
Jason and at a time he was talking to me
about the game that he dreamed to to to
produce and he was like but I didn't
find a team to do it I was like okay
maybe I know a team that can achieve it
i was at the time with a group of around
12 developers and we sat with Jason and
we explored a teddy a and from that 12
core people we add another 12 to work on
the on the pipelines and you can see now
with three years later we're more than
150 people constantly building over that
foundations but the foundation is pure
we have a lot of veterans who came back
honor to Ubisoft or in production to
work on that game I for myself was
presented that project over two years
ago by Jason when they were recruiting a
brand director for the game because I
was elping out for the recruitment and
halfway through I told the guy you can
go now I'm gonna take the job at the
time I was joking but six months later I
was joining the team so it's very
diverse but its passion unites us
the entire focus of the development on
this one has been built around a
breakthrough in the control scheme the
way that it works is very simple you
said your left stick drives your
character around then you lock on with a
Zelda style lock on the trigger and when
you lock on your right stick gives you
your control of your stances right left
and top stances and that actually moves
the position of your sword we just want
you to have the emotions of combat feel
like you are really holding that weapon
and that you're really dueling against
the other person the most important
thing to accomplish there is to get you
looking at your enemies stance and be
thinking about what they're doing and
trying to guess and anticipating what
they're doing these mechanics make that
happen what is really unique about
fallen off is that cough I chaining
experience it's not broader experience
it's not better meshing it's not also
fighter experience where you have to
memorize all the possible combos and
moves of your opponent it's something in
between it's something that feels and
play really close to the can of emotion
that you will have if you actually
fighting there is no game like that so
it's not like we are doing another
fighting game it's like we are creating
something from scratch that people don't
expect but suddenly as soon as they put
their hands on the pad they say this is
the game I always wanted to play but I
couldn't imagine it I couldn't I
couldn't think of that game before
Ubisoft has finally cracked sword
fighting that's what I'd like to see i'd
like to see this is the sword fighting
game we've always wanted because i think
that's what we set out to build